liebe leute herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute werdet ihr einen
kleinen videos zu sehen bekommen einen
besonderen wie glock wie sie nachher
noch aufstellen wird ihr habt
wahrscheinlich dem titel schon erkannt
dass es sich um einen roadtrip dreht und
das ging alles folgendermaßen los am
letzten sonntag hat mein kollege mehr
nacht und also guter freund von mir
nachts um zwölf geschrieben
hey ich hab keinen bock mal hier auf
deutschland was man es mehr fahren und
nicht weil abgesagt ich feiere solche
spontanen aktion absolut und deswegen
gesagt ihr 111 dabei haben wir alles
gepackt sofort losgefahren und aus der
reise ist das entstanden was jetzt
gleich zu sehen bekommt vorher noch eine
anmerkung die kamera hat ihre eigene
geschichte aber das wäre dir selbst
sehen
so liebe leute ich begrüße euch ganz
herzlich zu dem beginn von etwas was ein
ziemlich ziemlich geiler wieder ziemlich
geil dokumentation eines sehr
aufregenden abenteuer sein könnte denn
es ist jetzt halb zwei nachts und ich
ein kollege von mir die spontane idee
nach barcelona zu fahren das in 12
stunden mit dem auto way
wir sind jetzt gerade eine tankstelle am
vollgetankt was sagen gekauft alles
möglich was man für die fahrt braucht
und ja wir machen uns jetzt auf den weg
ich habe meine lege dabei der akkus auf
drei viertel
mal schauen wie ich damit aufhören kann
ich habe kein lader die corrida wie seid
ihr seid dabei soweit der akku reicht
und ich würd sagen lasst uns loslegen
aktuell befinden uns auf frankreich
schlossen wir haben
20 nach sieben wir sind seit knapp sechs
stunden auf der straße
und frankreich wieder ausgefahren eine
raststätte und da kostet einfach alles
minimum fünf euro als alles schon
irgendwie essen kann so eine packung ist
einfach fünf euro oder so nudelsalat
sieben euro also 37 euro die franzosen
die fand es klingt
das klingt klischeehaft ali fand alle
peugeot renault
was weiß ich alles was es geben sie
tragen und
das beste ist der blinker
also irgendwie blinken in frankreich das
gleich mit blinken in deutschland
jetzt schon mehrmals aufgefallen dass
franzosen ist drei mal so als kenne ich
die mittel einsetzen um sie jetzt dem
weg zur arbeit immer lustig
das kann erst passieren dass einer mal
eine minute lang links bringt aber
trotzdem in der mitte fährt und sich
bewegt
also wird sagen die sonne geht langsam
auch so langsam hier
was allerdings schon auffällt die leute
sprechen kein deutsch mehr
hier wurde der preis für eine schoko
wassertank in französisch vorgerechnet
und ja die bauernhäuser sehen noch
anders aus die nicht irgendwie man merkt
schon merkt schon ein bisschen dass man
in frankreich ist was aber maßgeblich
daran liegt dass ihr alles im kopf
stimmt aber gut also dann
weiter
ohne beleuchtung auf der pädagogischen
lernfunktion nachzukommen
so fährt man in frankreich auto
sie dürfte es ein mann fährt auf dem
mittleren streifen und blinkt vollkommen
ohne grund
herzlich willkommen in frankreich
leute was im hintergrund sieht oder
eventuell noch nicht seht dürfte darüber
sehen sind stadtränder von lyon eine
staatlich anerkanntes verkennt dabei
also nur trecker wir machen heute durch
ein fahrrad ganz natürlich
bekanntlich auch ein bisschen
verschlafen sehr schmutzige
industriestaaten vor
war glaube ich nicht nur die kasse
fraktion aber leute französischen
autobahnen so irre teuer werden für ca
1520 minuten autobahnfahrt
oder lassen der autobahnfahrt seien
einfach
30 eur 27 20 euro es ist komplett irre
also man sich dumm und dämlich richtung
autobahn a2
müssen wir schauen offen
also hoffentlich wird es nicht zu teuer
ganz so
wenn wir zu mir zu kommen allein und
karlsruhe darauf die autobahn weichen
müssen dann geht es natürlich nicht
wieder ein paar stunden später wir sind
mittlerweile in südfrankreich die
es ist schon ganz nah kann also die
leute sind schon ganz anders aus hier
die
bäume alles ganz einfach ganz anders als
in deutschland
und ja jetzt ist erst mal bastel
ausgeschert noch sind 430 km wir kommen
in zielnähe
wir sind einem dorf namens orange
vorbeigefahren und näher uns jetzt
abonnieren
das kann man wirklich
yahoo will so leute wir sind jetzt auch
einen rastplatz und kurz pause gemacht
und guckt euch das hier mal an
weil ich sehe dass das das geht dahin so
weit also hier sieht man dieses
wunderschöne einfach verboten in dieser
richtung aber er sieht einfach an den
bäumen wie sagt es ist einfach südeuropa
irgendwie aus irgendeinem grund es ist
ein mega faszinierend so kompliziert ist
die ganze doch voll krass was deshalb
nicht nur gewohnt selbst alles möglich
wieder glücklich dass an
das ist kein abgefragt platz in
deutschland das ist einfach einer in
südfrankreich wir sind jetzt bei nehmen
zu schnappen
es ist schönes häuschen hier genießen
bisschen die landschaft und dann geht's
weiter nach barcelona und jetzt die
große enthüllung wir sind wir leute
endlich angekommen in barcelona
das heißt so ganz will ich eigentlich
direkt gegenüber von der universität
barcelona universidad autonoma und er
ist zwar von bisher um gucken was so
passiert wie sie so früh angekommen sein
alter schläger
mit park und autos hat das 14 50 schon
gedauert oder so ja und dann leute ist
das malheur passiert der akku der kamera
war leer und die kamera war fujito so zu
sagen weil ich den leider nicht dabei
hatte es doch gerade ihm aufgefallen
dass ich einfach zweimal eine halbe
stunde lagen die innenseite meiner
tasche gefilmt hat das heißt ich habe
mich gar nicht wundern warum der akku
leer gegangen ist habe ich ihm etwas
passieren konnte
naja immerhin die waren auf den fall
danach richtig geil noch essen also wenn
ich im restaurant sowie waren hier auf
dem buckel
nur auf dem markt in barcelona und da
haben wir uns einiges geholt und das
hier mitgenommen diesen wunderschönen
batzen serrano-schinken mégane eis ultra
geil auf jeden fall ja und acht leute
was soll ich sagen sorry das ist so blöd
waren die kamera abgepackt ist es war
auf jeden fall ja die rückfahrt war auch
mega heiß werden keinen bock mehr auf
die mountain deswegen sind wir durch die
pyrenäen zurückgefahren deshalb
glücklich guckte ich das foto hier an
ja das haben wir gemacht war mit circa
8000 vier metern höhe es war einfach
sensationell es war so eine geile
erfahrung leute die gesagt einfach mega
ist wenn ihr die möglichkeit dazu hat
probiert das auch mal
es lohnt sich wirklich einfach mal raus
zu kommen was neues zu sehen genial
ja das war es von dem heutigen video ich
hoffe doch nicht gefallen checkt ab und
wir sind nächsten video wieder rein
macht gut an